al regresar al poder los talibanes
aseguraron que respetarían los derechos
de las afganas pero dentro de la ley
islámica en menos de un mes dan luces de
su interpretación de la misma el
ministro de educación superior ordenó el
fin de las clases mixtas permitidas
hasta ahora en las universidades en
adelante si se agregara a hombres y
mujeres bajando la ciudad cuando sea
realmente necesario los hombres también
podrán enseñar a las mujeres pero de
acuerdo con la sharia las alumnas
deberán llevar el velo también es
necesario que haya una cortina en el
aula los talibanes también habían
prometido un gobierno inclusivo pero no
nombraron a ninguna mujer como ministra
y por el contrario el ministerio de
asuntos de la mujer fue suprimido rujano
para los las mujeres deben luchar por
sus derechos y deben saber que esos
derechos les pertenece ahora eslavo
creaba esta tribu yaqui frente a estas
amenazas a sus libertades las afganas se
armaron de valor y se atrevieron a
desafiar a los talibanes en las calles
de kabul en varias manifestación
pacíficas
los nuevos líderes respondieron con
violencia golpeando a las mujeres e
incluso a los periodistas presentes
esta gente es muy injusta no son humanos
en absoluto
si nos dan derecho a manifestarnos no
son musulmanes sino infieles el sábado
se vio otro tipo de protesta un grupo
aparentemente formado por mujeres
vestidas con túnicas negras que las
cubrían de la cabeza a los pies se
manifestó en kabul en supuesto apoyo de
los talibanes y su estricta
interpretación del islam sin embargo la
presencia de integrantes del grupo
armados sugirió que la manifestación fue
organizada por ellos en una nueva
ilustración de cómo tras años de guerra
las mujeres de afganistán vuelven a
estar a merced del grupo